speaking of women in sports thursday
is baseball's opening day and boy have
we got the perfect guest here to
celebrate tiki
she is a former pro baseball player who
played in the all-american girls
baseball league
the real life league that inspired the
phenomenal film
a league of their own please welcome an
ace pitcher from southern california
maybelle blair
hey maybelle how are you oh god the old
girl couldn't be better kiki
oh i love it i love it all right
maybelle tomorrow
is opening day who are you going to be
watching
oh my god every ball game i could watch
but my dogs and my angels my red sox and
now
with the florida marlins on account of
uh uh kim yes first woman
general manager can you believe that
that shows the advancement
of women in professional sports we're
seeing professional uh football teams
have women coaches
right so we know that it's changing
slowly but surely it started because of
you
may belt can you believe that
this little 94 year old girl helped a
little bit
not much but oh my god i'm so excited
what's happening
mabel i have a question for you which is
you're young
it's in the 1940s obviously there's you
know
a a very different time for women
what is a good tip for young people
today
to hook into their passion the main
thing
today is to get out there and do your
darkness
because it is going to happen drew we
are going to open
up we're going to do our we're going to
get a new league in fact we're working
on it now
uh we're trying to get our own museum
going and uh
it's happening and if you love it follow
it because look at tiki sitting there
he probably didn't think he's gonna play
professional football but he did and
look what he did
and us girls can do the same thing and
we're so excited
that is so true but i have four
daughters i don't want them to be
limited by
anything so absolutely you're an
inspiration maebel
thank you so much for being you i mean
seriously you started something profound
and it's we're still feeling it
yeah absolutely my god i'm so thrilled
uh it has opened up college sports and
everything
now the wnba and i'm so proud of those
girls
they're doing their thing and uh girls
are getting scholarships
baseball is finally opening their eyes
that we can play
baseball so let us have an opportunity
to play it
let these girls have that that's what
i'm working for while i'm on this side
of the grass
well and all the data in the world
says that young girls who get involved
in sports
just have a better shot at like quality
focus
you know lovely friendships it's just
educational opportunities scholarships
all those things you're absolutely right
drew
thank you maybelle for showing
especially in the 1940s what was
possible and please go to our show
website and find out how you can support
women in
baseball and maybelles museum
oh my gosh
and you were at peoria red wing in fact
mabel we have a clock here
dedicated to peria illinois and our
affiliate station wmbd
oh how wonderful you can't do that
you can't and you can't beat you mabel
thank you so much for coming on the show
today
you